welcome everybody to the legislature and
upon request we are considering the fact
that the US Championship is being held
in st. Louis and today's lecture is
going to be dedicated for previous
participants of the US Championship and
how could we start a lecture about
American players without at least giving
a mention to Frank Marshall who was a
very sharp and great tactician
of course if parenthetically I can say
that if you're anticipating any Bobby
Fischer games I can show them because I
bet everybody else always does and it's
really a hit or miss on the chances of
you seeing one or not this game you
might have seen but I think that most
people haven't for example I've seen it
a long time ago and when I was
researching for this lecture it was like
oh yeah there's this game but I haven't
seen it in years so I'm hoping that you
guys you haven't seen it or haven't seen
it in a while so he was actually playing
a match against he an off ski back as
you can see as 1912 and you know to be
enough ski was actually kicking his butt
and he made up for it with this game I
think so sometimes you lose the match
but one game just we have such a good
taste in your mouth then it's almost
worth losing the match I think this game
was it so once again he is playing the
petrov and i showed actually another
class i don't know if it was I don't
know if it was the legend class was
another class where he was again playing
the petrov and people wondering why is
he playing the petrov when he is an
aggressive player well I think that this
game is going to be an example but not a
lone example there are actually great
attacking chances from the petrov white
is to be cautious in many lines so he
took here here here so far we are
following normal lines lines that even
till today are very playable Bishop to
d3 Bishop to d6 and again remembering
that this game was played like a hundred
years ago
c4 nowadays we know that c4 is not
urgent normally both sides castle then
c4 is played but this is not super
tragic so black castles
again why can still transpose by
counseling if I could have cancelled
again back I always like to say about
beautiful games sometimes one little
difference and the game would have been
just unknown this game could have just
disappeared but instead white decides to
try to refute the black strategy after
all the bishop is saving the knight and
the pawn is undermining the structure
from under so he decided to take bad
move really bad move but you wonder why
well before we even look for moves we
have to understand that for the cost of
a double pawn that doesn't seem the most
impressive thing in the world
Black is already cancelled and he has
two pieces out just like why does but
albeit the knight on e4 is better than
the knight on f3 and it's his move and
of course if you boondoggle here and
fall asleep then white is going to
Castle gonna complete this development
maybe God forbid he's even gonna get to
protect his extra pawn and make it prove
that it's worth something so now the
game really begins Chuck already at the
beginning of an inconvenient but
sometimes a move like this is just
disturbing the peace now what White has
several possibilities in the game he
played King to f1 because he concluded
that for example if Knight bTW to Bishop
f5 already it is becoming a big mess
notice that there's like a threat with
the night either like taking on d2 right
now and the bishop on d3 is unprotected
also I want to play rook e8 it's a
moment or maybe take him rook c8
needless to say that this is a very very
tricky position for white very
unpleasant so that was not very
appetizing alternatively you could have
played Bishop to d2 but then after the
natural takes already Black has two
bishops takes check again White has to
do something if he doesn't feel like
doing either move the bishop back or
move his King away so I guess this which
is as good as any and then Queen e7 even
Queen takes d5 is a good choice
regaining the pawn and life is really
good and of course Queen e7 just tells
you know what just don't counsel and
again there'll be quick development here
and I'd rather be black any day of the
week when white cannot castle so he
decided to play King f1 of course a
position like this is exactly to mark
Marshalls liking so in this position he
played Queen takes pawn not so much for
the sake of regaining the pawn but the
Queen gets active and of course the
knight on e4 needed support because the
bishop was attacking it now white played
Queen c2 probably the most logical move
I mean how else to complete the
development so Queen c2 seems to be a
pretty decent aggressive move and rook
e8
again the logical response why why move
the night you can just defend it with a
rock so in this position white is not
necessarily dying I mean he is it's
probably a tiny bit worse but again if
you put it to a cold-blooded computer
who has no emotions and no he doesn't
have a bad feeling about the fact that
he has a king on f1 maybe lagging a
little bit in develop and he cold
blooded Lee just plays the best moves
and probably maintains some sort of an
equilibrium however with a human it's
always very different so already he
makes a very big mistake as because I
wrote the I think this the land in the
computer suggested to play a three chase
the bishop away from the long diagonal
after Bishop d6 then Bishop e3 and
somehow white is regrouping next move is
Knight is gonna come out into c3 or d2
and eventually it's going to try to make
it so that he can cancel by hand easier
said than done and that's why of course
black is to be preferred but it's
certainly not the end of the world
we know who we want to be here black but
white is still alive instead after this
he decided to play Knight c3 okay so far
pretty understandable and again black
played what I thought was a forced move
he took hey white took back yeah I
should say that Bishop played seven if
you try to interpolate the move Bishop
here here and King h8 is going to
transpose to the game basically it's
gonna be almost the same as the game so
after this he took back
probably why thought himself that he is
doing pretty okay a he managed to get
rid of the menacing Center night that
gave him so much trouble he is attacking
the bishop his Center just improved and
not to mention in the offing he always
says Bishop takes a 7 winning upon but
marshal and dispositions was very very
strong
the fight was already kind of sitting in
his armchair or his chair comfortably
Marshall just played the move and I
guess the mood has changed BAM
Queen takes f3 well for those of you who
look puzzled I'll quickly explain
he took here if you would have taken the
Queen the game would have ended very
quickly after check check and rook takes
f1 checkmate kind of embarrassing so I
am positive that he knows he just
completely forgot about Queen takes
after me it was probably so busy
analyzing all kinds of lines seeing if
he can be safe and just forgot about
something well it's not really trivial
right so we took on before okay so very
nice and now I can tell you that the
position is so good for black after the
mistake Knight c3 that there are more
than this more than one way to win of
course you can play one move at a time
but I wonder if somebody could tell me
what is the best move by raising by
raising please raising hands because
other people so anybody just one person
to be poor anybody else yeah yeah Bishop
h3 I'm sure Julian you wanted to say the
same yeah bishop a story that's why I
give somebody else draw because I knew
you'd say right so Bishop h3 indeed is
the best move here and very very strong
and Marshall didn't play it I'm amazed
because the normal normally it Marshall
benefit the last person to miss
something like this you know it's kind
of a position you can take the Queen the
pawn is pinned if you take the bishop
Queen takes h1 mate and of course he's
threatening Quincy to mate so he would
have to play Brooke g1 let's take a look
at a variation now actually I don't
think I wrote it so we'll put it in
after here here and then this oops sorry
here and this is just a disaster this is
even worse than the game I mean the game
was bad enough
this was even would have been even worse
so okay he played knight c6 okay I'm in
this position all kinds of threats among
them Knight eggs before still of course
the the Queen cannot be taken so a real
fun game to play with black so in this
position Randolph's we thought to
himself okay what can I do play Bishop
b2 okay
probably the last mistake in the game
it's really it's really hard to advise
what to do I mean this pawn is hanging
this pawn is hanging the Queen is
untouchable Bishop h3 like we said is in
the offing everything looks good
hard to suggest a good move for white
here I don't even what the computer says
is best but I think it's beyond Salvage
so Bishop b2 and he played Knight takes
b4 again in this position
Bishop h3 just monster rook g8 Knight
takes b4 check otherwise the Queen moves
the bishop just goes King h8 and no move
anymore
there's just no defense everything is
hanging and this is just boss suddenly
computer said something like +4 from
black or maybe more so can do that he
played Knight takes b4 ok so we I have
to admit that when you ever move like
this that looks so great for black and
it gets a dubious sign you know the
blacks position is really really
fantastic so again why did Bishop 8 7 if
the Queen moves Knight takes Bishop is
very discouraging so this King h8 and
now he took the Queen okay looks like
the only move what else to do if you
move the the Queen away again Bishop h3
is strong 93 is coming the tons of good
moves
so here check
here Knight takes bishop takes at first
glance you think yourself that Marshall
just lost his mind because what the heck
he traded Queens when he was attacking
and now he is down on a piece not even
for one pawn but more careful look shows
you that again you have to not only
count the value of the pieces nominally
but also practically the King is now
trapped in a stalemate situation you
can't move the rook in the corner is
very bad and those two bishops are like
ducks waiting to be hunted so of course
the first move is trivial rook to eat
you obvious the two bishops are attacked
what to do needless to say you can move
the bishop lose the other Bishop on b2
and then of course it just makes no
sense to poop to play on because you
have no pieces that can do anything he
plays the most practical human move rook
c1 and now I want one of you to tell me
what do you think the best move is here
I must say that I I had the the game
shown with the computer already
analyzing in the background and I was
really taken aback by its suggestion I
don't think it's that hidden but somehow
I was really in there nanosecond that I
had to look for a move I didn't think
about it and then as it registered I was
amazed I promise you there's more than
one winning move that is for sure what
he played in the game was clearly a
winning a winning idea but what do you
think can that's what he played then who
can complain it was more than enough to
win I promise you because again with
many threats and it's winning material
it's just it's clearly winning but I
mean this is like there's something very
aesthetic about the there's the computer
suggestion okay like you said in the
game he said there's a but look at this
win rook takes c2 amazing no Queens on
the board you down a piece and now you
suck another exchange rook takes rook e8
threatened rook you want checkmate and
if the rook tries to save it or the
bishop tries to save it the rook c1
doesn't matter
Ruki six and there's no defense against
Ruby six made
so minimalistic really beautiful I
really I looked at this position maybe
for 10 minutes in my house because I've
never seen it I mean I've seen ideas
like this those of you who may know the
game more free Paulson also with Queen
takes Bishop f3 it's an A a game that if
you don't see if you ever see that I'm
recommending you to go to data bases and
see it at home as well beautiful game
and very similar motifs the King again
is kind of trapped with a bishop on h3
and a rook on the third ring but
something like this it's like apple Rock
no Queens extra tempo and good luck to
you checkmate is unavoidable really
beautiful okay so Marsha played the
human move again rooks 88 threatening
rook e1 and rook see - he tried to play
Bishop c3 again aniline that's really
worth analyzing courtesy of the computer
I have to admit Bishop a4 disconnecting
the rooks of course you can take the
bishop on b2 and be merry but again more
brutal is to play f5 again there's a
bishop to be taking on b2 in an endgame
and black says man not today let me
attack the other Bishop and again
totally losing because you can't take
the bishop can't move because rook e1 if
you try to save let's say one Bishop
with the idea that if pawn takes F 4 you
have disconnected the rooks and you
thought hey I've succeeded in something
well BAM again amazing just really
amazing now I want to go rook f6 g6 okay
of course you might wonder why not
rookie 6 but then f5 of course
everything is still winning but it's
just we're looking for the most
economical precise surgical way to win
the game
so root cafe now I want to go rook f6 so
d5 so that the bishop is attacking it
and now rook takes f4 and rook G for
checkmate is coming you can play f3 but
of course you can imagine did I continue
no but let me continue now after f3 I'm
gonna go into the wind me up check check
yes
let's take a look maybe Brooke takes up
three with the idea proc g2 here
yeah I'm buying it
yeah that's also mate isn't it yeah okay
mates all over yeah just fantastic so
I'm impressed again but he didn't do it
okay
he played Bishop c3 and I'm sure that
everybody now can see because well if
the exact example before impress you
it's more natural now he played rookie 3
amazing again notice that you cannot
play Brooke take c2 because the bishop
is defending a1 so he plays here just
monsters by the way of course if you're
wondering why he didn't play Brooke c2
here well of course the mate is
unavoidable but again you can play rook
e6 so if you wanted to you could have
done this this and this it's like a menu
it's a menu selection you can choose
whatever you want so yeah okay again
only one mini move for customer please
so either this and very depressing okay
now he played Bishop b4 to continue the
fight had he taken the rock then we have
another very beautiful windmill well you
win look how many pieces you're gonna
win in just like one move basically
right now black is up I mean white is up
a rock and a bishop okay exactly a book
in the bishop so check King of 1 there
goes the bishop and you have to go to e1
or g1 you know let's pretend that you
are pretending to protect your work for
a moment now check here and here so it's
really two rooks and a bishop with one
little maneuver just again no Queens on
the board to me this is just almost like
a composition very very beautiful okay
so like I said he refused the rock he
played here and now he just played here
idea rook F takes f2 and made bishop d1
impressive right is curing the rooks
rook f6 take my rock and of course in
this position you're not ski at all it
could take how to stop how to stop
Bishop rook g6 mate the only way is to
try to maybe play here but then of
course just rook takes and game over
very impressive performance by marshal
really one of Marshalls best games
everybody might know the game against
Levitsky when he played queen g3 and the
rumor about the gold coins that showered
the board of course that's a beautiful
move but overall I think with the man
with minimalistic forces that are here
this is really a beautiful example so
zero one okay so that's one game this
game is dedicated to my friend Arthur
best guy who I haven't seen in many many
years and we were teaching for many
years at the same just camp and one time
he was holding a book and he was showing
me his game against bent Larsen I didn't
even know he be bent Larsen I know he
played all the best grandmasters of the
60s 70s 50s and I know he beat Fisher in
a very famous game but he played him
several times but this game just
completely blew me off because Larsen in
1965 was already a very very strong
chess players chess player you hear some
of you might know that he became one of
the top players on the rating list and I
world candidate just after that so here
he is playing someone who is low rated
my score was lower than him but watch
what happens again swashbuckling style
d4 g6e 4 ok very typical both players
are not super experts in the opening and
are willing to experiment with different
style base score by nature is a default
player but he is not shying away from a
modern defense Larsen plays everything
that ever moved over the board right he
can play any move that was played he can
play it very famous for beating Karpov
from the black sides of a Petrov and
playing all kinds of weird openings so
here again this growl is definitely not
waiting immediately the vienna structure
against the
more than peers d6 9 f3
and of course if the after 9 f6 if the
game would have played Knight c3 and
then either castles or c5 it would have
been a very normal
opening but Bishop plays Bishop d3 again
with this move order you can
differentiate because then the pawn on
e4 wasn't attack early on so the knight
can be delayed from being developed that
can be useful sometimes because in some
lines when an c5 is played then you
always have a c3 in the offing should
you choose to just maintain your Center
and now lost and played the move castles
which is normal White Castle Knight d7 a
very committal move in my opinion I
think that Larsson was very kind of
throwing caution to the wind I think
that normally you will play something
like 96 or Bishop g4 and we just have a
normal kind of peer structure but
instead he does this and I have to tell
you that even a simple simple chest like
I'm ok he played ephod but another thing
that I think that I mentioned that is to
play or like let's say like Queen e2
soon of let's say Queen e2 with the idea
that on c5 what are the break would you
have to play then just d5 and we have a
really ugly version of a benoni
for black because normally black already
played something like e 6 and pawn takes
pawn takes or C takes and now the night
on d7 is really clumsy when you play e6
I might just take it and you always have
to worry about me playing a 5 black is
going to be left with a really funny
pawn structure so that was also
positionally right but in this game B
Square was in no mood to play positional
chess he just saw the guy with a target
right here on GA to see the target yeah
that's the target and he hunted it until
he got it and boy did he get it so it
all starts with oopsie with E 5 all
right now it was time for black to be a
little more alert he had to understand
that in this position he has very
serious mass of pawns and potentially
pieces coming after him and he should
have played more aggressively he played
the move Knight to e8 I really don't
like that I think that 95 is much more
challenging
he's kind of actually trying to provoke
ceefor because night before and creating
some disharmony in the black art in the
white army that would have been a lot
more challenging I'm assuming busier
maybe would have played something like
c3 to maintain the structure and I love
white I rather be white than black of
course you know Bishop c8 is weak and
where is this night going but that would
still not be as passive as 98 okay again
Arthur can build any which way he wanted
you you can play many many illogical
moves but he decides to just neglect
notice that this Queen side is not
really moving right now and it's not
gonna move for the near foreseeable
future he decides to just build an
attacking position by playing Queen e1
we know the Queen is heading diagonally
to the Kings side and Larson decides
that he's gonna play the thematic move
when white goes big center try to gain
space you gotta somehow break it strike
it on the side c5 very very logical even
the computers are proved and now f5 now
the computer really doesn't approve of
this move but if I have to give it a
some sort of a real notation which the
computer doesn't allow because it
doesn't have that notation I would
probably say something like exclamation
mark and then two question marks because
it's not really justified objectively
against the computer he probably would
have paid but in practicality this is a
very hard enough to face and very hard
move to punish so in the game he played
D takes e5 and more interesting or at
least to understand what happened if he
breaks at the foundation with C d-four
then F takes G 6 e 6 is another line
pawn takes Queen h4 pawn takes Knight g5
9 f6 92 black is in some danger because
well white has some annoying ideas of
playing here but Bishop f5 can be played
in this position believe me there is a
difference between this position and the
one that you will see in a second here
Bishop a5 rook takes f5 is very exciting
again if I have a nine hour lecture we
can go over all the intricacies of the
position however now
so just you have to just believe me that
after analyzed with the computer it's a
very exciting position something kind of
similar happens so he took on e5 and
bitter are very wisely takes on g6 and
now very interesting would have been to
play F takes G six the point is that
after here Queen h4 takes this pawn
bishop check here Knight g5 Knight f6
this is in blacks favor because yeah
sure you can win the exchange any day of
the week but after rook takes Bishop
takes I've gotten to center pawns for it
and there is no meeting attacking again
look at those guys the spectators on the
left so okay very well
so after takes he takes with the H pawn
so again having given one point on e5
base gray is in no mood to regain it he
just wants to continue the initiative
and now Larson has to take on d4 there's
no other choice okay I don't get too
many conflict to complicated with the
analysis I can tell you that II takes d4
and C takes d4 are very similar he took
and now basically played the second best
move
he played again one of the principle
move in the position he wants to soften
up the black defense this Bishop is very
annoying especially with those two pawns
it's a fortress so he played Bishop 286
but I can tell you that after Knight g5
9 f6 what else Knight d2 and coming to
e4 and this is a disaster now after
Bishop f5 rook takes f5 is just watch it
takes takes I think I stopped around
here but already there is no defense I
mean I'm just coming here with my knight
if you attack my bishop on e6 I have
checked on 87 King h8 94 again if you
put it in the computers you can see that
white is just much much better and when
you're done material the computer says
you're much much better it basically
means you're winning okay
the game didn't fare much better for
Lawson but because he made a mistake
after 84 Bishop 8 6 he played
the very bad move night eat app sex
again
it's like many times we have to choose
which rook to bring to the open file
here it was which night should we bring
to f6 to defend the poor King from his
troubles and he chose the wrong night
much better would have been to have
played Knight D here and after Knight g5
Queen d7 and the idea is to play queen
g4 already forcing white to make some
time losing concessions and black can't
survive again courtesy of the computer
so let's see what happened after he made
a mistake he played here Knight g5 and
you could already tell that black is in
deep trouble white as a classical
attacking stance against the Dragon
Kings Indian type of Bishop position and
this is already very very bad news so in
the game he played 95 and that really
compounds his problems but I gave one
example that will suggest that b5 just
to show you how bad the situation is for
black after b5 that looks like some
chances on the Queen side right trying
to keep shift the attention from the
King side why just played the monstrous
Bishop takes g6 with a very simple idea
okay there should be seven of course if
you take on g6 I just stay here if you
try to take back then bye-bye Queen yes
definitely a big Oh and yes and
otherwise after Bishop e7 Bishop 8 792
the attack just plays itself black
cannot move any piece basically Knight
f6 can't move Bishop g7 can't move you
can move the rook so what and the King
is not exactly where he wants to be so
very very impressive like I said in the
game he played Knight e5 hoping that you
know maybe he can just get rid of this a
very very unknowing Bishop and again a
very bad day bad hair day for Lawson
will just completely miss the following
I'm sure some of you can already see it
everybody want to take a guess of what
was played in this position
Julian if Bishop g7 King takes g7 rook
takes f6 King takes f6 not a pretty
picture I agree but the game might go on
but there is a shortcut I mean maybe if
it's winning yes
rook takes f6 game over all of a sudden
its moves move 14 and Larsson can resign
let's analyze why he couldn't take back
the rook that's already a said statement
now why after E to accept six of course
very simple Bishop g7 and now you have a
choice of which mate you want to get if
you take the knight then it's on h8 if
you take the bishop then it's 187 white
is very unpick e here so that was out he
of course could have also taken with the
bishop and then white would have played
the very aesthetic Bishop g7 with
exactly the same idea however you take
you get made and if King takes its mate
if Bishop takes its made otherwise I'm
threatening credit retake the night then
Queen h8 is made again mating galore
alright so what to do Larsen could have
resigned with the clear conscience
but I guess it's kind of embarrassing to
resign against someone higher alien you
and your top Grandmaster in 14 moves so
he decided to play on he played Bishop
h8 giving this car at least a chance to
go wrong because you might say wait a
minute didn't I just take a knight how
about if I keep hunting how about if I
play Bishop takes the rook on a fade but
he just retreated if you take on on f8
then after this ok again I think I want
to be white rather than black but this
is already becoming messy like I always
tell my students when they have a
winning position and they start getting
funny I say here you already have to
think in the other position you don't
have to think so
of course no go rook f1
rook e8 trying to save his rock bishop
f8 alright just because the square is
empty doesn't mean we can't release them
it of course it's a clearance sacrifice
I'm dying to get my Queen into business
here and the bishop is really in my way
so he just went here of course the idea
is very simple if the rook retreats then
it takes away the king escape square and
queen 87 is checkmate if the King takes
the Queen takes Bishop is checkmate
what's worse some protein Queen eight
seven and who innate shape made anyways
so Larsson played the move Bishop f6
hoping that now the bishop on f8 is on
pre and basically I told him wait a
minute didn't you get my message from
before second time same square really
very very aesthetic can you imagine
playing Larsen at that almost almost
well he was close to the peak of his
career and twice you sacrifice a rook on
f6 and twice you're doomed once again he
could have resigned right here and save
himself one and a half more moves of
suffering but I guess he decided to
oblige [ __ ] cry he took em our [ __ ]
girl played the last move yes yes Queen
eight six again a very aesthetic move
simply threatening Queen g7 made and
Larsen again I guess by now I think he
probably paid his next move with a smile
realizing that he he really got beat he
played here and that was the point
Queen h7 made not every day you get to
make bent Larsen in 19 moves very very
impressive
never moved yeah I mean this is I'll
never show this game to my beginner
students because how am I going to
explain
rokay one and I'd be one I'll never live
to hear the end of it so yeah a very
impressive game by Bisgaard
hope you enjoyed it and as a dessert
we'll see a game by Walter brown against
Christensen something slightly more
modern if you could call 1977 Morton is
still a pretty old game and Walter had
many many good games where he sacrificed
many many pieces even though he's a
positional player but especially in his
younger days he was also not afraid of
sacrificing even in d4 openings you can
get into very aggressive position where
you can make your opponent so d 4e 6 ok
c4 b6 Larry was trying to be I guess as
tricky as possible because at that time
I can tell you 1977 Walter Braun was
just an encyclopedia of theory he really
really knew his stuff and he was the
funny thing is if he was playing almost
the same lines both his white and black
so it was supposedly easy to prepare
against him but when you know so much
and you have so much experience sure he
paid the price here and there but it was
a very risky thing to do so Larry is
trying to mix up things and Walter
immediately deviates this move is not
new even then it wasn't the first time
it was used but the normal line is to
play like efore Bishop e7 Bishop d3 is a
very famous line sometimes they even
played the move a3 saying hey I'm about
to build a really strong Center so why
should i why should I suffer with Knight
c3 Bishop before okay Walter goes
straight ahead Bishop a6 again like I
wrote not my favorite move I really
think that Knight f6 is slightly more
accurate you know kind of controlling
otherwise well in the game you see what
happened white gets to play E for
undisturbed why allow that he took takes
of course C takes is not that great
because Bishop takes f1 Knight f6 Knight
to c3 again
Walter is just playing very directly I
think that many players would have
preferred to play Bishop d3 so as to not
allow
the bishop to pin the night maybe then
black would apply bishop before check I
don't know if it would have made a huge
difference so Knight c3 bishop - before
Queenie - check
so Walter is trying to win an endgame I
guess because he has a little more space
after Queenie 7 it would have been
unavoidable but again Larry Q since in a
very aggressive player by his own right
is trying to not trade Queens doesn't
want to go into a slightly inferior
ending and he brings the bishop back he
justifies the retreat of the bishop in
the fact that the Queen is blocking the
pieces and will have to spend the temple
as a matter of fact it's paying the
temple right now Queen c2 c6 Bishop d3
I'm sorry
Bishop to d3 b5 okay now that is too
much I know the Clary is a very active
player he really cannot stand being
slightly behind in space and development
but this I think is really asking for it
you cannot have less space worse
development I mean when I say what's
development I mean worst active
development where your pieces are more
passively placed and get away with a
strike immediately before you are ready
so first Walter takes attack to the
bishop pawn takes very very nicely
thinking well if white takes on b5 then
the pawn on d5 is going to go
of course Walter has none of it he plays
Knight e2 by the way very interesting
would have been to play Knight f3 with
the idea after this to play here again
it's a pawn sack but with a lot of
initiative if you tried to show it to
your computer he shows you ample
compensation if black even dares playing
Knight takes d5 here ok so he played 90
to b4 he wants his pound of flesh he
wants his pawn Walter says no problem
and he took so we can see that Larry is
really playing a very provocative game
he's sucking he takes the sacrificed
pawn
saying hey I believe I can consolidate
I'm not far away from canceling and
therefore why shouldn't I just take the
pawn and enjoy it
alright so walter castles very castles
some of you might say wait a minute
didn't black just win a pawn answer
No watch what happened you'll see rook
to d1 of course there's an isolated
backward pawn on the D file and why
shouldn't we just put a look right
behind it very logical Queen a5 the most
aggressive response Knight g3 very very
good move you can see that white is
definitely having something to show for
the pawn the fact that planet has if you
just count the material and you just say
Oh black has an extra pawn on b7 he must
be winning no he's not winning because
the point is not queening or anything
but on the other hand white doesn't have
enough initiative to really win the game
it's not like oh the attack is just
unstoppable Walter we'll do our best to
play but Larry had to help a little bit
so g6 this is the beginning of a very
bad idea
he should have just bit the ball between
the bullet and allowed the knight to
come to f5 continuous development and
again it'll be a lot of proof on why
that he can do something after g6 the
weakness is starting to tell step one
Bishop 86 a freebie not only the bishop
is developed to the most promising an
aggressive spot but at the same time
tempo over the rock rook to e8 Queen d2
again he is something that the dark
squares are gonna be good news and now
he is proven right the best part is she
will have been to play takes takes 97
moved the night away here here okay
somehow black is semi consolidating
after 96 again I you know white has a
great game but and of course probably
double you have to give up the bishop
but still black the burden of proof is
on white no question about it instead
after this move he played Knight f6 in
itself illogical move the knight on d5
is very vulnerable and the knight on e4
is a better piece and he says okay then
maybe we should just strayed Knight well
not exactly
Queen f4 already we can see that there's
the beginning of an announcement of
pieces around the black King the
the Queen the two nights in the bishop
they're all kind of going here
Brown is starting to develop a nice
attack so here Larry must have thought
okay it's time to reduce the material a
little bit because if not those pieces
are gonna get me so he played I'm sorry
first he played Queen b6 well the the
lines behind the scenes are also very
very beautiful
let's see some lines let's for example
see Queen d8 Bishop a6 here Knight f6
here rook takes d7 hi a visitor and now
of course complete disaster block is
just collapsing if rook if Queen takes
the seven Queen takes f6 it's just the
end of the game so okay let's see
something other variation after Queen f4
if you would have played Bishop d3 here
Knight f6 King h8 of course you cannot
take Knight xe8 and Queen takes f7 I
mean black is just collapsing what else
could have been played Knight age five
and I take stage five Queen takes h5 g4
and the poor Queen is embarrassed after
Queen here Bishop takes takes rook d7
threatening rook takes a seven and the
bishop can't move because Queen f7 what
can I tell you a disasterous position
from black just complete collapse so he
tried to play Queen b6 and here Bronk
could have body play Bishop h6 is also
not too bad but look at this variation
that the computer suggested here with
the obvious threat of 9 takes f6 and the
bishop on e7 is pinned so takes Bishop
takes tickling the rook in the corner
knight c6 Bishop d5 and again an example
just to stand just to wait and look for
a moment of how bad the position is
everything is um pre f7 with mate the
root can't come to f8 not only because
the bishop is attacking it but I'm also
attacking this and this
everything is groggy the Queen look at
how the board is divided between the
bishop and the knight are all here
completely over
so after Queen b6 white played Bishop
takes rook
I mean Knight takes and again brown
played a move for the crowd
rook d6 what a beautiful disturbance of
course he was attacking this knight
twice he really wants to get his Queen
to f6 because then g7 will be undone
avoided then defensible and what to do
now I'm basically forking the Queen and
the knight now the knight is attacked
three times and it's defendant only once
if the Queen just moves I'll take the
knight so reluctantly Larry had to take
Knight takes f6 of course of course
Queen takes f6 Bishop f8 and there's no
maid so he took King King h8 for a
moment we say okay the black king is not
a pretty picture but between saying that
and winning the game there's still a
very big mountain to cross and he played
Bishop g7 Chuck I have to say that night
h5 would also work in this position also
when you move according to the computer
but this was also very nice Bishop g7
you got a take not h5 check another
beautiful sacrifice and he took if you
would have played here because King h8
queen eight-six is not very fun still
nine eight seven if King is 7 Queen f6
is checkmate so here then check check
check
looks very gruesome the Queen on b6 is
gone and terrible so if we go back after
Bishop g7 check takes and takes check
and of course if Queen f8 Knight xd7 is
not only a Royal fork but also checkmate
so we have to go to the corner Queen
eight six
who would have thought that that was
once an innocent D for opening right
with a positional structure so Bishop
takes h2 King h1 you can also take on h2
it's not so bad but this is even funner
Queen takes f6 what else how else to
stop me there is no way so we took took
here Queen g5 check here Queen f6 check
always repeat according to my good
friend Ben triangle and then he just
took the bishop not only is white up
material but the position the black
position if you look at the pawn
structure it looks like something that
got punched by Mike Tyson right it's
like really looks broken up completely
rookie six the rest is really just
simple technique will show it for
history sake root d1 picking on one pawn
okay so we move the Queen picking on
another pawn you're not gonna get my
Jeep on yep
all the pawns are falling like pac-man
tickling tonight and in this position
Larry head or it could take after the
night moves he's gonna be lost white I
mean I don't know
can you even save the night maybe you
can go 984 but after rook takes f6 and a
minimum the position is extremely
discouraging to play so larry threw in
the towel a very beautiful attacking
game by brown not his only one
all right guys we are done thank you
very much for attending my lecture I
hope you enjoy the show see you next
time you knew exactly when to enter
exactly